so one common type of problem that you
see in a number of multivariable
calculus classes will say something to
the effect of the following find and
classify all of the critical points of
and then you'll insert some kind of
multivariable function so first of all
this idea of a critical point basically
means anywhere where the gradient equals
zero so you're looking for places where
the gradient of your function at some
kind of input some specified input X&Y
that you're solving for is equal to zero
and as I've talked about in the last
couple videos the reason you might want
to do this is because you're hoping to
maximize the function or two maybe
minimize the function and now the second
requirement of classifying those points
that's what the second derivative test
is all about once you find something
where the gradient equals zero you want
to be able to determine is it a local
maximum is a local minimum or is it a
saddle point so let's go ahead and work
through this example the first thing
we're going to need to do if we're
solving for when the grading equals zero
and remember when we say equals zero we
really mean the zero vector but it's
just a convenient way of putting it all
on one line we take both partial
derivatives so the partial derivative
with respect to X is well this first
term when we take the derivative of 3x
squared times y with respect to X that
two hops down so we have six times X
times y Y cubed well Y looks like a
constant so Y cubed looks like a
constant minus three x squared so that 2
comes down so we're subtracting off six
times X six times X and then again this
3y squared term Y looks like a constant
so everything here looks like a constant
with zero derivative as far as the
x-direction is concerned and we do
partial of F with respect to Y then this
first term looks like some sort of
constant 3x squared X looks like a
constant so some kind of constant times
y so the whole thing looks like 3x
squared the second term minus X cubed
minus y cubed excuse me looks like minus
3y squared when we take the derivative
minus 3y squared and then this next term
only has an X so it looks like a
constant as far as Y is concerned and
then this last term we take down the 2
because we're differentiating Y squared
and you'll get negative 6y negative 6
times y
so when we are finding the critical
points the first step is to set both of
these guys equal to zero so this first
one when we do set it equal to zero we
can simplify a bit by factoring out 6x
so this really looks like 6x x y -1 and
then that's what we're setting equal to
zero and what this equation tells us is
that either
it's the 6x term that equals zero in
which case that would mean X is equal to
zero or or it's the case that Y minus 1
equals 0
in which case that would mean that y
equals 1 so at least one of these things
has to be true that's kind of the first
requirement that we found let me scroll
down a little bit here and for the
second equation when we set it equal to
zero it's not immediately
straightforward how you would solve for
this in a nice way in terms of x and y
but because we've already solved one we
can kind of plug them in and say for
example if it was the case that X is
equal to 0 and we kind of want to see
what that turns our equation into then
we would have well 3x squared is nothing
that would be 0 and we'd just be left
with negative 3y squared minus 6y is
equal to 0 and that we can factor out a
bit so I'm going to factor out a
negative 3y so I'll factor out negative
3y which means that first term just has
a Y remaining and then that second term
has a - a positive - since I factored
out negative 3 so positive 2 and that
equals 0 so with this whole situation
would imply is that either negative 3y
equals 0 which would be which would mean
y equals 0 or or it would be the case
that Y plus 2 equals 0 which would mean
that Y is equal to negative 2 so that's
the first situation where we plug in x
equals 0
now alternatively there's the
possibility that y equals 1 so we could
say y equals 1 and what that gives us in
the entire equation we still have that 3
x squared because we're kind of solving
for x now 3 x squared and then the rest
of it becomes let's see minus 3 times 1
squared so minus 3
in one for y and then we subtract off
six plugging in that one for y again and
that whole thing is equal to three x
squared then minus three minus six so
I'm subtracting off nine so from here I
can factor out a little bit and this
will be three multiplied by x squared
minus three and what that implies then
since this whole thing has to equal zero
what that implies is that x squared
minus three is equal to 0 so we have X
is equal to plus or minus the square
root of three and maybe I should kind of
specify these are these are distinct
things that we found one of them was in
the circumstance where x equals zero and
then the other was what we found in the
circumstance where y equals one so this
gives us a grand total of three
different critical points because in the
first situation where x equals zero the
critical points that we have well both
of them are going to have an x
coordinate of zero in them x coordinate
of zero and the two corresponding Y
coordinates are zero or negative two so
they have zero or negative two these are
kind of two possibilities and then
there's another two possibilities here
where if Y is equal to one when y is
equal to one we'll have X is positive or
negative square root of 3 so we have
positive square root of 3 and y equals
one and then we have negative square
root of 3 and y equals one so these
these are the critical points critical
points which basically means all partial
derivatives are equal to zero and then
in the next video I will classify each
of these critical points using the
second partial derivative test